-You know, I saw you quickly
at the Met Gala
that was here in New York.
It was a beautiful thing
that raised a lot of money.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And, man, you were a knockout.
You looked gorgeous.
You stuck to the theme --
Look at this, Gilded Age.
-Thanks.
-Look at this dress.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, what -- is that --
is that all hand -- hand done?
-Yeah. One of the coolest things
about this dress is,
it was built here in New York.
It weighed 70 pounds.
-7-0, 70 pounds.
-7-0.
And it had 25,000 gold
paillettes that were hand-sewn.
So, I think one of the coolest
things about the Met Gala
is that it's an opportunity for
designers to dream really big.
And Joseph Altuzarra
created this gorgeous dress.
It was brought to life
by all these
New York-based master craftsmen.
And it was -- I mean, it's an
honor to wear this beautiful,
beautiful dress.
-What is it like walking around
with 70 pounds on you?
-I napped
for three days afterward.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I did some pilates
in preparation.
I mean, it was heavy.
I feel like --
It took us about an hour
to get there
in the car because of traffic.
So, I was standing so I didn't
disrupt the paillettes.
And by the time I got there --
-Wait.
So you're standing in a --
-I was standing, like --
standing, like, you know,
just trying not to bite it
on the way there.
-Wow.
-And then, by the time
I got there, then you wait
in a line before you
then walk up about 50 stairs.
-Yeah.
You really have to have stamina.
-Really got a workout.
-So you threw down a couple --
ate a couple of power bars.
-Yeah, exactly.
-"All right, I'm almost there.
Hold on."
-Eat some jerky on the --
you know, in the line.
-Yeah, exactly.
And did you get to --
when you went, finally,
to the Gala, did you walk around
and talk to people?
-Absolutely not. No.
[ Laughter ]
I got there, and I was like --
-Laid on the ground?
-"Thank God,"
and just sat down
and didn't move
the rest of the night.
At one point,
I braved going to the bathroom.
And everybody just looked at me
like they felt sorry for me.
You know,
I was walking so slowly,
and my whole dress was going --
kwk! kwk! kwk! kwk! kwk! --
down the hall of the Met.
-Unh!
-And then, at some point,
I ran into Lizzo,
who looked incredible.
-Yeah, she's cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I -- oh, my God.
She looked so amazing.
I'm such a fan.
I am someone who kind of
short circuits when I meet my
heroes, and I just saw her,
and she looked at me,
and she went, "Marvelous."
And I was like, "I -- you --
you -- oh, my -- you --
I just -- pfft! -- you are --
you are -- you are --"
and there was nothing
out the other side.
I just said, "You are..."
for like 5 minutes.
-You are, yeah.
"You are."
-You are.
-Yeah.
-You just couldn't think
of how to finish it?
-If she was a fan,
she isn't anymore.
[ Laughter ]
But she was lovely.
And she --
-Do you freak out?
Like, do you get --
do you, like, fangirl out?
-Y-Y-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I --
The last person that --
I ran into Jon Stewart
at a Knicks game, who was like,
"I love the show,"
and I was like, "You are --
You are -- You are Jon Stewart."
-"You are Jon Stewart.
Absolutely, you are."
-"You are him."
-All right, well, Lizzo,
Jon Stewart, if you're watching,
Rachel's a fan.
-I --
-And you really are.
You really are.
-You are.
-You really are.
[ Applause ]
-That's all they need to know.
That's all they need to know.
How are the dogs?
Last time, you were nice enough
to come on our show through Zoom
'cause of COVID and precautions.
-Yeah.
-And we did yoga with our dogs.
-We did.
-Yeah.
-Which, they were -- mine was
better than yours at yoga.
-Yeah, my dog, Gary,
was like, "I'm good."
-Yeah, Gary was like,
"No, thank you."
-Yeah, no.
-No, the dogs are good.
I -- I took them to see
a pet medium recently.
-Wait. A pet medium?
-Mm-hmm.
A pet medium.
So, she promises
to connect deeply
with your dogs, psychically,
and then tell you about them.
So, you know,
I feel like I went into --
-This is fantastic.
-Yeah, so I'll give you
her number.
-I have to do this.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-So, she can tell you
what the dog's thinking.
-Yeah, what they're thinking,
what they're feeling,
what their dreams are.
-Walk me through this.
What happens?
Where is she?
Where are you?
-So a friend of mine swore
that this pet medium cured
their cat of flying anxiety.
-Okay.
-And so I thought, you know,
my pets could certainly
be cured of some anxiety,
so I should give
this pet medium a call.
And, you know, I thought,
like, I'm a skeptic.
I'm not someone --
I should clarify that to this --
I'm not someone who's like,
"Sign me up for a pet medium.
That's what I need in my life."
-Yeah, you need a little
convincing.
-Yeah.
And so, I was like, "Okay.
Yeah, I'll give the pet medium
a try."
You know, best-case scenario,
I form a deep
and intimate relationship
with my dogs,
and worst-case scenario, I have
a great story to tell you."
[ Laughter ]
And --
-All right, I want to know
where this kind of lands.
-Neither of those things
happened.
-Okay. Okay.
Interesting.
-And she goes, "Do you have
a question for them?"
-Oh.
-And we're like, "Yeah.
You know, I feel like everybody
kind of wants to know, like,
what do our dogs think of us?
What do they think of us?"
And she goes, "Okay."
[ Breathes deeply ]
-Now, is she holding onto
the dog's paw or anything?
-Well, no, she's on the phone.
-She's on the phone.
So I'm just imagining that --
-Wow, she's got a really
good connection.
Yeah.
-She's on the phone.
She's got a deep connection.
-Deep connection over the phone.
Okay.
-She goes --
-"Let me hear the dog breathe."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She goes,
"They think...
you're fine.
They think you're fine."
[ Laughter ]
And we were like...
-Like, "Where do I Venmo
the money to?" Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, yeah.
And then we go, "Okay, okay.
All right. You know,
we're gonna go with this.
"What do they think
of each other?"
And she goes, "Mm, mm-hmm.
They...think they're fine."
[ Laughter ]
And we were like --
-You're amazing.
You are amazing.
-"Okay. All right."
And it went on like that.
And eventually we're like,
"Okay, obviously,
this is B.S."
So we start asking her
all these leading questions.
We're like, "You know,
we've got to get at least
something funny out of this."
-Yeah.
-So, one of our dogs, he stares
into space very intently.
And we've always wondered
if he sees dead people.
[ Laughter ]
So, we asked her --
We're like, "She's got to have
something good to say."
-Yeah, she has to have
a few tricks in there.
-"Madam pet medium,
does Winston see dead people?"
And she goes, "He...
thinks there
could be food there."
[ Laughter ]
We were like --
-Please do not give me
this woman's number at all.
Yeah.
-No, but here's the thing.
If I was a pet medium...
-Yes.
-...it is a service to humanity,
right?
People need this kind of hope
in their lives.
If I was a pet medium,
and people were like,
"What do my dogs think of me?"
I'd be like...
-"They love you."
-..."They think you are
maybe actual royalty.
They've never seen it before.
They think you are a --"
I mean, what would you say?
-Of course, I would say,
"Oh, my gosh.
Both of your dogs
are so impressed
by how you stand up
on two legs."
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Yeah, you're welcome.
-And now I feel better.
-Yes, and you feel better
about yourself.
I'd have a whole list
of fun things like that.
-And if you're like,
"Does Winston see dead people?"
I'd be like, "Yes.
Yes, he does."
[ Laughter ]
-Why not? Yeah.
-It was a royal disappointment.
And I'll give you
her number anyway,
in case you want
to give it a go.
-Yeah, and I'll get a story,
and I'll give you my story.
-Thank you. Please.
-I want to talk about this,
'cause I love podcasts.
And this is a scripted podcast
on Audible,
"The Miranda Obsession."
This is a true story.
This is a real thing.
-So, it's inspired
by a true story of this woman
named Miranda Grosvenor,
who was a model,
kind of socialite, in the 1980s,
predominantly.
-Yeah.
-And she would call
some of Hollywood and sports
and music, sometimes politics,
most famous men and developed
these intimate relationships.
Not sexual.
Like, intimate friendships
and things with them
on the phone.
And not all was exactly
as it appeared.
And you'll have to give it
a listen to find out why.
-But how did the story get out?
-So, there was an article
written in 2000 in "Vanity Fair"
that talked about --
It interviewed
a bunch of the men.
You know, Billy Joel,
and I think
Paul Schrader was interviewed.
You know, it's a bunch of these
men who spoke about their
experiences with Miranda.
But that story was told largely
through the perspective
of the men.
A male journalist, you know,
did the research on this.
It's a really, really brilliant,
interesting article.
But a team of women --
you know, my partners,
who are a bunch of women,
we wanted to just dig
a little bit deeper
into this story and look at it
through a female lens
and see kind of
why she may have
made these calls,
what prompted her
to pick up the phone,
and what she gained from it.
So, this story is kind of an
exploration of all those things.
-Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-I mean,
"The Miranda Obsession,"
right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about
"Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
-Yeah.
-You know, we love you so much.
And I've had you on the show
for that great show.
But now, it's just announced you
got picked up for season five.
And it will --
[ Cheers and applause ]
But season five
will be the final season.
-Yeah.
-Of the series.
-Oh, my goodness.
Now, is that bittersweet,
or do you go, like, "Nope.
I kind of know
Amy will wrap it up""?
-Well, both.
You know, it is definitely
bittersweet but also know that
she's gonna wrap it up.
It's gonna be an epic
last season.
And it's gonna be full of
twists and turns and surprises.
But definitely bittersweet,
yeah.
I mean, Amy --
Amy let all of us know
that it was gonna be
our last season.
And I actually saw her
later that night.
About once a year,
I take her out for Irish coffee,
I get her wasted,
and I make her tell me
what's gonna happen
in the next season.
But this time,
it was more bittersweet.
No, this time,
we just kind of reminisced.
And so,
heading into this season,
I know absolutely nothing
about what's gonna happen.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, nothing at all.
I have no idea.
-I know season four was --
a lot of it was shot
during the pandemic,
and the shutdown,
and everyone had to be safe.
-Yes.
-And I think that you came up --
or someone came up
with some invention for you
that I've never seen before.
Because you couldn't
really wear a mask,
because you wear wigs
in the show.
-I wear a wig.
Yes, yes.
-Yeah.
And beautiful hats.
-So, but you can't --
-I couldn't put a mask
over my ears.
-The lace on the wig.
-Mm-hmm, yeah.
-So you invented something
called the --
This is the co-brella.
-Well, I wish I could take
credit for this invention.
This had nothing to do with me.
Our COVID team
came up with this solution.
There's a little --
there's a little HEPA filter
right here that filters the air
inside my literal bubble.
I was the bubble girl
for six months.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah.
So you would go from your
trailer to the set or wherever.
-Yeah, trailer to the set,
wherever I needed to go.
Would hold this little umbrella.
-Every day.
-As adorable as it looks,
by the end of the season,
I was ready to throw it
into the Hudson.
[ Laughter ]
Or, I'm ready to, you know,
one day, I feel like,
when future humanoids
dig up our piles of trash
out of the depths of the Earth,
they are gonna find this,
and they're gonna have
a lot of questions.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, or just donate it to the
Paley Center just to see, like,
what we did for TV.
-Yes, that's right.
Yeah.
-I think you're phenomenal
in this, and I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Rachel Brosnahan
in "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
Take a look at this.
-No more opening-act gigs.
-What?
-I will only do gigs
where I can say what I want.
-Midge --
-That's what Lenny would do.
-That's different.
He's Lenny Bruce!
-Well, then make me Lenny Bruce.
Make me a headliner.
-How am I supposed to do that
if I can't even book you?!
-I don't know.
You're my manager.
Manage me.
-Miriam, I hear you. I do.
But you know, as well as I do,
that's not
how the business works.
-Then let's change the business.
-Yeah,
"Let's change the business"!
Rachel Brosnahan, everybody!
Season four of
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel"
streaming now on Prime Video.
And all episodes
of "The Miranda Obsession"
are on Audible right now.
Jack Harlow joins us
after the break.
Stick around.
Come on back.